je voudrais préfacé par une préface et
c'est très vrai présentation par une
citation de la loi du 6 février 1992 qui
figure d'ailleurs en tête de ce rapport
et qui est l'administration territoriale
de la république est assuré par les
collectivités territoriales et par les
services déconcentrés de l'état et je
voudrais souligner que plus on regarde
ce sujet puis il me semble qu'il s'agit
de deux faces d'un même problème
les réformes de la décentralisation la
réforme régionale touche les services
déconcentrés de l'état à leur tour
l'évolution des services déconcentrés
n'est pas sans incidence sur le
fonctionnement des collectivités
territoriales est au fond une des
remarques qu'on peut se faire en préface
de ce sujet c'est que on regarde assez
peut-être trop rarement ces deux
problèmes ensemble et et que la
déconnexion entre les réformes j'allais
dire de l'administration territoriale et
l'extension de la décentralisation et
les différentes réformes dont la réforme
des régions sont trop déconnecté qu'on
voit que l'une retenti sur l'autre
souvent sans qu'on ait le loisir de
l'est de les articuler
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire des services
déconcentrés la lumière du rapport de la
cour des comptes
premièrement si l'on subit une vraie
réforme
ce qui n'est pas le cas de tous de
l'ensemble de l'état cette réforme c'est
celle de la de la réate au début les
années 2010 et dont j'étais rappeler
quand même qu'elle est elle n'est pas
sans incidence sur le plan des effectifs
ont un divorce en des effectifs pour le
périmètre de la de la réate
donc les services je dirais
d'administration pure qui entourait
soutiennent l'action des préfets aurait
at on a les trois principaux réseaux
territoriaux de l'administration de
l'état
le réseau de l'éducation nationale le
réseau de la police et de la gendarmerie
et le réseau des finances publiques
les deux premiers de ces réseaux n'ont
pas été diminué en effectif non
seulement ils ont pas été les milieux un
effectif mais l'analyse que nous avons
conduite dans le rapport que je vous ai
cités madame la présidente sur les
services publics en milieu rural me
conduit à dire que notre analyse est que
ces réseaux n'ont pas déserté les
territoires y compris les plus les plus
j'allais dire les plus éloignés de du de
l'administration centrale et qui est que
ces réseaux se sont ré adapté mais qu'en
volume en tout cas est globalement
considéré ils n'ont pas diminué il en va
autrement du réseau des finances
publiques qui est en cours de
décroissance à l'époque de notre apport
cette décroissance s'amorçait -10% sur
les années qui avaient précédé et se
continue et il ya un besoin de
rationalisation de ce réseau qui
comporte encore comme vous le savez des
postes des postes de la dgesip à moins
de dix agents etc et donc il ya besoin
nécessaire de de rationalisation quels
étaient les deuxièmes remarques
préliminaires si je peux me permettre
c'est que
7 le fait que cette véritable réforme
est eu lieu va de pair avec l'image est
incertaine d'une certaine stabilité
l'administration territoriale qui est dû
à deux de deux éléments principaux
le premier c'est le rôle des préfets les
préférées c'est une image fixe ans quand
bien même leur mission changer leur
statut d homme va changer prochainement
et deuxièmement la la carte d'un certain
nombre d'administrations territoriale ne
s'est pas beaucoup modifié il en va de
la carte des sous-préfectures non non
modifiés pratiquement depuis 1926 il en
va ainsi d'un certain nombre de réseaux
dont le réseau judiciaire
les tribunaux de première instance
certains ont vu leurs cartes modifiées
une réforme réussie mais la carte des
cours d'appel des 37 cour d'appel n'a
pas été modifié donc il ya une sorte de
contraste entre une réforme réelle et
une apparence de stabilité due à la
persistance en particulier de la carte
de la carte des sous préfectures
alors les 3 la cour a délivré à 7
à l'occasion de cette enquête trois
messages principaux et trois séries iv
série de recommandations dont le premier
message c'est que
il fallait approfondir la réforme pour
recentrer les services déconcentrés de
l'état sur ses missions sur ses missions
prioritaires
on avait procédé au fond à une forme de
rationalisation bienvenue mais de
réduction homothétique des moyens sans
peut-être hiérarchisé et prioriser
suffisamment les l'émission
par ailleurs vous l'avez souligné madame
la présidente les réductions ont affecté
de certaines missions en mettant
certaines en risque les deux que nous
avions identifiés dans le rapport de
2017 était premièrement les missions de
contrôle un certain nombre de missions
de contrôle dans le domaine des
installations classées de sécurité
sanitaire que sais-je nous avait paru en
risque et deuxièmement je le mentionne
parce que certes nul n'est prophète en
son pays mais nous avions écrit je cite
que les contrôles de la cour ont mis en
exergue des interrogations sur les caps
la capacité de certains services à faire
face aux crises sanitaires de grande
ampleur donc la réponse aux crises nous
avait parlé un peu fragilisé sous
l'effet sous l'effet de deux de la
réforme
cette réforme était naturellement
utilisait un levier de transformation
très important qui est le levier
numérique
les grains de productivité liés à la
dématérialisation d'un certain nombre de
procédures avaient fait partie de la
réate et à la suite de l'arrêt at dupe
et png sur lequel a travaillé
directement jean-michel une l'air et
donc il pourra vous dire vous dire un
mot deux mille 2000 tp économiser avec
la réforme relative à la délivrance des
titres à laquelle j'ai fait j'ai fait
allusion ont cependant il y avait et il
y a toujours des ddd des limites je
dirais à l'utilisation du levier
numérique et notamment dans le
cloisonnement persistant d'un certain
nombre de systèmes d'information qu'il
s'agisse des systèmes de l'état est
d'ailleurs dû des systèmes de l'état et
des collectivités territoriales le
rapport en citer un exemple intéressant
qui était que les logiciels qui
permettent l'instruction par les
les intercommunalités ou les oeufs
où les communes des demandes d'urbanisme
mais n'étaient pas compatibles avec les
logiciels qui permettaient ensuite
d'asseoir les taxes découlant de ces
deux de ses procédures et par conséquent
ressaisie manuels etc
bon c'est évidemment la preuve qui a
encore beaucoup de progrès à faire dans
l'utilisation pour des choses très
simples et au bénéfice des citoyens du
levier du levier numérique
il y a aussi des marges au delà de la
réforme accompli il y avait selon nous
des marges de progrès dans l'exercice
des missions des services déconcentrés
et place pour une plus grande
rationalisation parce que
l'administration territoriale au fond se
partagent entre eux quatre niveaux le
niveau national bien sûr et il ya
certaines missions qu'on peut concentrer
au niveau national par exemple les
missions de contrôle les plus sensibles
et les plus pointues pichot des
installations aux très faibles donc sur
le territoire national nous situant cet
exemple le niveau régional le niveau
départemental et plus en plus le niveau
interdépartemental puisque aussi bien
les la suite su repartir et la réforme
des régions les services département les
services de l'état s'organise au niveau
au niveau interdits moraux
départementale ce que nous pensions
devoir encourager il ya un certain
nombre de
deux missions qui se situe mieux dans ce
dans dans ce chan d'une façon générale
il semblait à la cour que le niveau et
je dois dire à l'époque la réforme des
régions n'avaient pas produit tous ses
effets peut être nous dire nous pas tout
à fait la même chose aujourd'hui et le
niveau qui nous paraissaient devrait
être le point d'appui le sorte de ne
s'être à tj de l'organisation
territoriale entre ces différents
échelons nous paraissait que le niveau
le niveau régional et nous semble
essentiel qui est des plateformes qui
aident à ce niveau les services
départementaux ouvre les
sous-préfectures et donc c'était le
niveau que nous avions sélectionné si je
peux dire et identifiés comme devant
être devant être renforcée
quelques ombres au tableau néanmoins on
est dans ce paysage de réformes en cours
premièrement l'état ne tirait pas
suffisamment toutes les conséquences de
la de la décentralisation
on citait des exemples de compétences
qui étaient manifestement plus du
ressort de l'état qui reste est exercée
on citer par exemple les fonctions de
soutien au tourisme des directs lors que
c'est manifestement une prérogative
maintenant et les collectivités
territoriales
la propension des services de l'état je
cite a assuré dans certains secteurs une
fonction de coordination d'ensemblier
mal définis en particulier dans le
domaine social ou les compétences
départementales de justifier peut-être
pas de maintenir de la part des services
préfectoraux un rôle de coordination
encore une fois relativement
relativement floues
et enfin dernier levier de
transformation qui évidemment en tension
avec l'objectif de déconcentration donc
il faut y faire attention c'est le
transfert de certaines compétences à des
agences ou des établissements publics
spécialisés c'est un élément de
complexité supplémentaire l'efficience
peut recommander une spécialisation de
ce type et qui du coup créer des réseaux
territoriaux ou d une action locale qui
échappe aux j'allais dire au regard et
la coordination par les préfets
dans le deuxième message c'est
évidemment que l'état devait ça ne vous
surprendra pas s'ajuster aux
conséquences aux conséquences des
différentes réformes
touchant les collectivités territoriales
et tout particulièrement la réforme
régionale l'état de façon intéressante
ça rejoint ce que je disais sur le lieu
l'heure citant l'article qui divise au
fond l'administration territoriale entre
les collectivités territoriales et
l'administration déconcentrée et l'état
a subi les mêmes problèmes au fond que
les régions et les administrations
régionales à la suite de la réforme
régionale et tout particulièrement dans
les plus grandes régions en certes on a
supprimé 144 services régionaux du et un
63e groupe et 63 nouvelle entité 63
postes de directeurs régionaux ont été
supprimés donc il ya eu des efforts
considérables de fait mais on a eu
l'état s'est trouvé face au même dilemme
que les régions organisation multi sites
absence de regroupement des
fonctionnaires concernés autrement que
sur la base du volontariat les mutations
n'ont pas été forcés et les contraintes
indemnitaire dans le regroupement des
agents il ya là dessus un rapport de la
cour des comptes sur une première
analyse de la réforme régionale qui met
en exergue ces surcoûts liés à la
dispersion des services le fait que les
services régionaux sont maintenant multi
sites etc et l'état n'a pas lui-même
échappé échapper à ces critiques
la distance en particulier entre dans
les quatre régions comportant plus de
départ plus de dix départements entre le
j'allais dire l'échelon de pilotage
régional et les départements pause pause
pose à l'administration territoriale des
problèmes importants comme il les pose
au niveau des collectivités les
collectivités territoriales par ailleurs
le regroupement des régions n'a pas
empêché la persistance de découpage
dérogatoires qui sèche une c6 de
l'éducation nationale de la justice j'ai
cité les cours d'appel de
l'administration pénitentiaire et ses
allées sont les départements maintenant
l'échelon départemental avions-nous note
t avait été plus affecté que l'échelon
régional par les baisses d'effectifs et
c'était c'était particulièrement vrai
dans dans un certain nombre de jaillir
de deux services regroupés dans les deux
ou trois directions qui ont succédé aux
douze directions départementales des
services de l'état avant là avant la la
la la réate
et donc il y avait là il y avait là je
viens et un souci une réduction plus il
ya peut-être plus que nécessaire à
certains endroits de l'échelon de
l'échelon départemental
cela contrastait avec une situation du
réseau infra départementale donc
essentiellement celui des sous
préfectures qui restait dense et qui
évolué lentement comme nous l'avons dit
dans le rapport que j'ai cités sur les
services publics en territoire dans les
territoires ruraux
l'état demeure fortement présent à
l'échelon infra départementale
contrairement à certaines idées reçues
mais il reste présent dans des
structures qui ont été pour certaines
d'entre elles fragilisé et j'ai cité on
peut citer à cet égard les 60 sous
préfecture qui comporte à présent moins
de dix agents
ce qui évidemment appel appelle une une
réflexion parmi ces difficultés de faire
coïncider les circonscriptions
territoriales de l'état entre elles un
exemple particulièrement frappant de 2,2
de jacques de découpage et répartition
des responsabilités sur le plan
territorial qui nous paraissaient appelé
appeler une réforme appelée des
corrections étaient le réseau
administratif de l'éducation nationale
je parle pas du réseau des
établissements les différentes
circonscriptions d'administration du
ministère de l'éducation nationale
enfin troisième message c'était un
message sur la gestion regrouper les
services modifier la carte des
responsabilités fonctionnelles des
services territoriaux de l'état
au fond ça ne c'est jose dire ça ça n'a
qu'une portée limitée
si les responsables qui sont à la tête
de ces services n'ont pas la latitude de
l'espion qui correspond au nouveau
périmètre de responsabilités qu'on leur
assigne et tel est bien le cas des
blocages très importants dont les
principaux sont des blocages en matière
de rh les regroupements au laisser
subsister sur le plan des ressources
humaines et la gestion des personnels
des systèmes de gestion encore très
fortement centralisée pour certains
d'entre eux l'impossibilité pour ces
nouveaux responsables d' entité
fusionnée d'arbitrer sur le plan du
personnel entre les personnels issus des
anciennes directions qui avait été
fusionnées et un niveau de
déconcentration de la gestion du
personnel très variable selon les
ministères dans ces entités regroupées
donc des freins extrêmement important à
une bonne gestion locale de
l'administration territoriale sur le
plan budgétaire même chose c'est-à-dire
que le si on regarde et c'est ce
qu'avait fait la cour à l'époque le
volume des crédits déconcentrés mais
qu'on en retrancher dans les dépenses
obligatoires qui sont les dépenses de
personnel on voyait que la marge de
manoeuvre effectif
des pressés puisque c'est ce dont il
s'agit à l'échelon à l'échelon des
dépenses au niveau des dépenses
déconcentre et est en fait beaucoup plus
réduite on ne pouvait le qu'on ne
pouvait le penser et que les les jets
étaient allés capacité d'arbitrage et de
décision budgétaire à leur niveau était
et est tout à fait insuffisant c'est ce
qui nous amenait à conclure que la
descente la déconcentration des moyens
et financier demeurait partiel et
demandé à être approfondies et nous
recommandions en particulier pour les
fonctions support des services que j'ai
mentionné la création d'un bloc régional
unique des fonctions support de services
de l'état en notant que des progrès
énormes étaient à faire dans ce domaine
dans deux secteurs clés qui est l
immobilier est là
le numérique champ dans lequel les
progrès de la mutualisation devaient
être accélérées en fin de ces les 49
recommandations je vous les épargnes
bien sûr de la cour étaient regroupés en
quatre grands chapitres que je vais vous
mentionnez
et puis j'arrêterai là cette
présentation recentrer les services
déconcentrés sur les missions
prioritaires de l'état et répartir de
manière plus efficace l'exercice de ses
missions entre les services concernés
faire des deuxième orientation faire des
services publics numériques à levier de
transformation les services déconcentrés
de l'état et jean-michel là pour un
sujet vous parlez des leçons que nous
tirons du bng si vous le souhaitez
accélérer l'adaptation de l'organisation
territoriale des services de l'état et
dernier message mais pas le moins
important c'est un davantage confiance
aux services déconcentrés dans la
gestion mutualisée décloisonner de leurs
moyens c'est à dire donner c'est le
plaidoyer en fonction faveur d'une
déconcentration effective qui donne aux
gestionnaires locaux est évidemment au
premier lieu aux préfets les moyens
effectifs de la déconcentration que je
crois tout le monde appelle de ses de
ses voeux voilà merci beaucoup madame la
présidente
merci beaucoup monsieur présents avant
de passer la parole d'abord à mes deux à
nos deux collègues rapporteur agnès
cannes et éric kerrouche serait ensuite
collègues je voudrais juste peut-être
faire un commentaire sur le point que
vous avez évoqué d'une évolution des
services territoriaux de l'état en lien
avec les réformes d'organisation
territoriale puisque les différentes nos
eaux territoriales du quinquennat
précédent on positionner la région comme
un acteur qui était un acteur en tout
cas une échelle de pertinence pour
l'action des services de l'état puisque
on pensait qu'on pouvait gagner et
optimiser les ressources et les moyens
or si on a vu qu effectivement à
l'échelle des services déconcentrés de
l'état qu'il pouvait y avoir des sortes
de mutualisation de ce que j'appelle
maladroitement des fonctions support ce
que traditionnellement les fonctions aux
supports sont les fonctions de back
office mais je pense qu'il ya des
organisation possible d expertise en
tout cas qui peuvent se retrouver au
niveau régional et ensuite nourrir
l'échelon départemental force est de
constater que toutes les analyses de ces
tickets ont été faites ont été
violemment bousculée par la crise
sanitaire qui a mis en évidence ce
qu'aujourd'hui on appelle le couple
préfets maires non pas parce que
soudainement la commune reprendre la
puissance et le préfet on retrouve mais
c'est parce que nous avons aussi
beaucoup de politiques qui sont
articulées entre les services de l'état
et les collectivités locales et que trop
souvent chacun avance noces au silo et
dans son couloir et qui n'y a pas cette
culture de l' échange de la coordination
et du lieu de dialogue et je crois que
là nous avons une difficulté qui n'est
pas qu'une quiche vous l'avez dit
monsieur présent qu'une question de
moyens ou de ressources mais souvent une
question de méthode de travail
je passe la parole à agnès canayer
ensuite eric et rouge propose si vous
êtes d'accord
cher rapporteur de consolider vos
questions et ensuite de donner la parole
aux présidents pour vous répondre si
vous êtes hockey sur cette option merci
à vous
j'ai la parole merci madame la
présidente monsieur le président
monsieur le conseiller effectivement pas
de décentralisation sans déconcentration
je pense que nous sommes tous d'accord
sur ce principe et on voit aujourd'hui
notamment à l'aube de l'examen de la loi
cadets que
il existe encore un certain nombre de
fragilité notamment dans l'organisation
des services déconcentrés de l'état que
vous avez pointé dans votre rapport de
2017 devrait revenir sur l'efficacité
gestion des services déconcentrés est ce
que vous prenez c'est à dire la
hiérarchisation des missions qui sont
celles qui sont dévolues aux avis
déconcentrer le premier ministre à
prendre une circulaire le 19 avril
dernier demandant à ce que soit mis en
oeuvre
c'est une véritable hiérarchie dation en
lien avec les services territoriaux et
des services centraux pensez vous que ce
sera avec tables moyens pour renforcer
cette efficacité est ma deuxième
question c'est que vous pointez aussi
entre autres le rôle et du numérique
comme un moyen pour améliorer le rôle de
l'état déconcentré
avez vous eu une analyse vous pouvez
vous me dire si véritablement c'est une
piste très d'amélioration de cette
efficience
merci merci à ma planète remercie le
président si le président monsieur le
conseiller
suite à la reprise de leur prise de
parole
plusieurs plusieurs réflexions qui leur
font qu'ils leur font écho
je vais couper ma caméra parce que j'ai
pas assez de bande passante voilà désolé
vous demandez d'abord vous avez parlé
des de la situation des des sous
préfectures qui effectivement à ma
connaissance non pas était revenu une
revue depuis poincaré en 1926 ça fait
pratiquement ça fait gratuitement
sentant et vous nous avez indiqué
notamment que certaines de celles ci
comporte et elles étaient toujours
présentes mais comporter moins de moins
de moins de dix agents
quel est le sens encore
de leurs actions faut-il procéder à des
regroupements au niveau infra
territoriales quelle serait la bonne
manière à champ que en france
l'arrondissement préfectoral
arrondissement du sous préfet est une
subdivision qui n'a jamais pris de sens
territorialement par l'ons le deuxième
point c'est la situation que l'on
connaît depuis la création des préfet de
région en 1964 en fait avec tantôt une
réaffirmation du préfet de région et
tantôt une réincarnation du préfet de
département
la question c'est comment on fait
aujourd'hui et plus exactement c'est est
ce qu'on doit faire de manière uniforme
c'est à dire le préfet de région préfet
du département touati v exactement avoir
le même type de pouvoir en fonction de
la base territoriale c'est sans doute
pas la même chose à préfets de région
dans une région fusionner qui a douze
départements comme la mienne ou ou dans
une autre bref quel quel niveau et
pertinent et l et quel niveau
d'équilibré
par ailleurs le dernier point s'agissant
des ressources humaines vous avez parlé
des difficultés notamment deux ouvrages
de management
s'il y avait une deux voire trois
mesures à prendre qui serait à prendre
en priorité en la matière quelle
serait-elle
je vous remercie beaucoup merci monsieur
le président si vous voulez bien
répondre à cette première série de
questions ensuite il y a deux demandes
d'intervention notre collègue antoine
lefèvre qui est en présence et les
charles guené qui monsieur visio merci
monsieur prix merci beaucoup madame la
présidente je vous propose qu'on se
partage les rôles e jean michel lair et
moi même et ce que je peux
l'huile et le sujet et qu'il réponde aux
questions de madame la sénatrice
canadienne et ensuite j'essaierai de
répondre à celle de du sénateur et rouge
merci madame la présidente a été évoquée
effectivement cette les feuilles de
route ministérielles qui ont été prévus
par là la circulaire du premier ministre
2 avril 21 ont fait un dispositif qui a
à priori va dans le bon sens comme tout
toute démarche qui vise à définir des
priorités à fixer des objectifs et à
mettre en place surtout derrière un
dispositif d'évaluation de la mise en
oeuvre donc nous avons un a priori
positif sur sept ce type de démarche
j'observe en particulier qu'il y a comme
point fort dans cette entreprise une une
adaptation prévu au plus près des
besoins des territoires avec une
co-construction qui part de la base et
qui remonte ensuite vers
l'administration centrale pour une pour
une synthèse c'est un fait un premier
point intéressant deuxième point
intéressant c'est la possibilité pour le
préfet de demander des adaptations de la
feuille de route s'agit donc pas d'une
de consignes rigide fixé une fois pour
toutes il ya des possibilités
d'adaptation et d'ailleurs je crois que
les préfets ont l'obligation au bout de
trois mois de faire un premier point
avec avec le ministère de l'intérieur
sur
sur la les l'avancement de cette
démarche le troisième fois important à
mon sens c'est le souci de la continuité
de l'état puisque la feuille de route
s'adresse non pas un préfet mais a au
préfet titulaire du poste quel qu'il
soit même s'il ya changement
quatrième point important cela la
feuille de route vise la mise en forme
la mise en en de réformes et de
politique publique prioritaire mais
également de projets structurants qui
peuvent d'ailleurs être les projets de
transformation des services déconcentrés
de l'état donc que l' approche est assez
assez large
et puis dernier point important dans
tous les cas une évaluation doit être
lancée sur la base d'indicateurs qui
sont accompagnés de deux cibles à
atteindre
bon évidemment beaucoup de recul pour
apprécier ce dispositif je crois qu'il
ya plusieurs points qui seront
spécialement à à suivre d'abord comment
s'effectuera la priorisation des enjeux
des actions et des projets là il ya
toute une mécanique qui devra se se
mettre en place et sur laquelle nous
n'avons pas encore beaucoup de
d'expérience deuxième point important
comment est traitée ce qui n'est pas
prioritaire parce que on reste que ce
sera une gestion qui risque d'être un
petit peu dégradées ou pas il ya un vrai
problème
troisième interrogation comment feront
fera t-on convergent lui et l'allocation
des ressources avec les objectifs fixés
c'est très bien de randonnée l'indiqué
des objectifs et des priorités mais il
faut que les ressources suivi quand je
parle de ressources et les ressources
financières les ressources humaines les
ressources en ont nagé nieri au sens
second souffle large du terme
et puis dernier dernière interrogation
quelle sera la portée des évaluations de
2002 la mise en oeuvre qui seront qui
seront réalisés en fin de processus hors
froid qu'il ya des expérimentations qui
était prévu au cours de l'année 2021
nous aurons probablement quelques
quelques compléments de précisions sur
la façon dont les choses se se déroule
voilà ce qu'on peut dire sur ce point là
encore sans beaucoup de recul
quelques mots sur le problème de la
numérisation la la la cour a abordé ce
sujet ont là encore nous ne pouvons
raisonné que sur la base des travaux
réalisés par là par la 4e chambre de la
cour et nous avons examiné le problème à
l'occasion de de l'étude de la
dématérialisation de la délivrance de
certains titres parlée par les
préfectures et au delà des difficultés
transitoires qui ont été liés à la mise
en place en l'espèce extrêmement rapide
d'un nouveau dispositif il faut bien
convenir que la la dématérialisation la
numérisation ne permettent pas de régler
tous les problèmes
le processus a été lancée très
rapidement beaucoup trop rapidement sans
doute et plus vite que ce qui est
observé en général pour l'adoption de
démarches en ligne quand il y a
parallèlement maintenu une une
alternative d'accès physique
traditionnelle et cela a entraîné une
véritable difficulté d'accès de certains
usagers certains se rappellent sans
doute parler pour les cartes grises
difficultés liées à la révolution de de
l'accès et à des problèmes de techniques
de l'informatique qui avait été problème
qui avait été largement sous-estimées
donc il ya eu des dysfonctionnements des
coûts supplémentaires générés par la
nécessité de revoir le dispositif est
donc la leçon qu'on peut tirer déjà sur
ce point c'est qu'il ne faut pas aller
trop vite mais laisser mûrir ses projets
pour éviter ensuite les surcoûts
financiers
en définitive sociaux au sens où sens
large et en particulier nous avons noté
que un travail préalable indispensable
n'avait pas été menée c'est celui de la
simplification préalable de 2,2 du
dispositif réglementaire
ce travail n'avait pas été menées dans
des conditions satisfaisantes et on a
simplement greffée par la suite un
dispositif de numérisation ça n'a pas
bien marché même si l'administration
après après les mesures satisfaisantes
en rien un deuxième point il ya un
deuxième point c'est celui de l'accès
des populations qui sont réfractaires au
numérique
c'est un c'est un vrai problème qui a
sans doute été encore sous-estimé au
départ sous-estimé au départ donc on a
créé le mystère a créée ultérieurement
des points d'accueil numérique entre
effectué et ses points numérique ne
devait être que transitoire puisque ils
devaient ensuite se fondre dans ce qu'on
appelait à l'époque la l'aimé sap et qui
sont devenus ensuite les maisons france
service
mais compte tenu de la très forte
demande des usagers le ministère a
décidé en définitive de les maintenir en
administration préfectorale en
complémentarité avec les skis étaient à
l'époque les msa paix nous des problèmes
d'articulation entre les deux mais ça
c'est du reste c'est un petit peu un
petit peu secondaire par rapport au
point de fonds en tout cas la chambre à
travaillant sur ce sujet a remarqué que
dans beaucoup de départements
on avait beaucoup de difficultés pour
recruter des jeunes volontaires qui soit
capable de faire vivre ces points de ses
points de ses points d'accueil est donc
ce n'est pas une solution
ce n'est pas une solution idéale mais
elle elle est dans certaines régions
assez assez difficile à mettre en place
l'accompagnement des usagers c'est une
vraie difficulté
3 troisième france qui concerne les sous
préfectures
en l'état c'est un débat qui mériterait
des heures de discussions dont je ne
reviendrai pas sur le sur le fond des
problèmes
on connaît tous la difficulté du sujet
puisqu'il ya à la fois des problèmes de
gestion des ressources humaines
d'immobilier d'autre part la nécessité
de tenir compte des évolutions de la
population dans les différents
territoires
la nécessité de s'adapter à l'évolution
des missions du ministère de l'intérieur
dont je reprendrai pas je je je
reviendrai pas sur ce débat là cour
avait formulé quelques propositions
tendant notamment à détacher 6 plaisir
les sous préfets des arrondissements ce
qu'on peut dire c'est que des quelques
évolutions intéressantes ont été
organisées par dans certains
départements puisqu'on a pour colmater
en quelque sorte les vide créé par le la
disparition de certaines missions en
sous préfecture
on a créé des pôles départementaux
c'est à dire des équipes qui basé dans
une sous préfecture et exerce des
compétences de la préfecture pour
l'ensemble du département en matière
funéraire en matière de 2,2 d'armes à
feu en matière de d'organisation de
manifestations etc
c'est une démarche qui est intéressant
c'est ce que permet de 2,2 de
rationaliser un peu le réseau de des
préfectures et les sous préfectures
à condition qu'il soit bien pensé c'est
à dire faux pas il faut pas simplement
créer un pôle départemental dans une
sous préfecture pour occuper un vide
mais il faut que ce soit réfléchie est
ce que c'est le meilleur endroit est ce
qu'il ya les bons agents qui sont
susceptibles de répondre à ses missions
et ses terrains non il se passe des
choses mais c'est effectivement
relativement marginale par rapport à la
problématique générale
voilà ce que je pouvais dire sur ces sur
ces trois points
merci monsieur le président
ce que vient de dire jean michel lahaye
ya de toute évidence une un travail de
réflexion et clarification global à
faire entreprendre sur l'arrondissement
les sous-préfectures qu'est ce qu'un
sous-préfet
c'est à la fois une sorte d'incarnation
physique de l'état mais sans et puis en
même temps c'est celle d'un petit
service qui est celui les sous
préfectures
je crois que ça appelle une réflexion
d'ensemble et la cour le recommandait à
dire dans le rapport de 2010 7,2 et en
même temps probablement en tout cas
c'est ce que suggérait la cour qu'une
réflexion sur la carte des
arrondissements bon on va tout ça est
éteint est un sujet qui est devant nous
mais en écho aux interrogations de du
sénateur kerrouche ne peut que dire que
nous les aigles et les partageons enfin
et que nous les avons rendu rendu public
chaud les préfets de région
évidemment un élément nouveau dans ce
qui est maintenant la la la la sto
ration non seulement d'une répartition
fonctionnel d'aider des rôles mais d'une
forme de hiérarchie entre préfets de
région et préfet de département avec une
complexité supplémentaire due au fait
que l'échelon zonal l'échelon des zones
des zones de défense se renforce dans la
gestion de lutte contre le terrorisme
dans l'administration de la police
avec la création de directions d'un
journal de la police nationale et les
gars me donc je je je je je sais pas un
sujet sur laquelle la cour et est
travaillée publié donc je ne peux pas
répondre avec j'ai dit rassurant sur sûr
sur cette question mais très
certainement il ya on s'apprête à lancer
une enquête d'ampleur sur la haye le
sujet des préfets et du rôle des préfets
les interrogations vos interrogations
aussi le sénateur seront très présentes
à notre esprit c'est évident que le
préfet de région dans une région
plus de dix départements et dans une une
région
je parle pas même les régions mono
départementales ou bi départemental où
il y avait quand même à préfet de région
comme ça existe encore un autre mais
tout ça ne tout ça mérite mérite
évidemment qu'on le qu'on le regarde de
plus près et qu'on le regarde comme vous
le suggérez en liaison avec la
problématique de la différenciation et
de l'adaptation de l'administration et
et des modes décentralisation aux
situations locales
donc ça moi je ne peux que souscrire à
cette réflexion tout en disant qu'elle
est en s'agissant de la cour des comptes
devant nous nous ne l'avons pas encore
formellement entreprises sur le là où
nous avons des réponses plus précises à
vous apporter monsieur le sénateur c'est
sur ce qu'il faudrait faire en matière
de gestion des ressources humaines dans
l'administration territoriale en a effet
à l'époque en 2010 7,9 recommandations
elles vont toutes dans le même sens il
voulait réduire le nombre de cores aller
vers des corps interministériels avoir
une répartition homothétique entre les
différents corps déconcentrés de l'état
de l'échelon de gestion pertinence est
complètement anormal que dans le même
service i 1
régionales ou départementales y ait des
personnels dont l'avancement relève de
l'administration centrale îlot du préfet
localement tout ça n'a aucun sens
donc il ya un énorme travail de
rationalisation diminution du nombre de
cores de de l'harmonisation des
responsabilités de gestion des
ressources humaines au niveau au niveau
pertinent et si possible à un niveau
déconcentré et j'ajoute que la course
s'est toujours montrée favorable à sinon
des recrutements régionaux au moins les
concours nationaux affectation régional
pour rapprocher les j'allais dire les
agents du lieu de doubs lieu d'exercice
de leurs missions dernier point il est
tout à fait anormal qu'un certain nombre
de revalorisation indemnitaire et plus
avoir lieu à l'occasion de justement du
rapprochement des corps sans
contrepartie était imposé des
obligations de mobilité on est quand
même ce que ce que dit jean michel lair
et à très juste titre sur le fait qu'on
a pu spécialisée certains pôles en
sous-préfecture dans l'exercice de
fonctions départementale
c'est quand même la contrepartie c'est
faire de nécessité vertu
sachant que certains personnels vous
pouvez pas les obliger les obliger à
bouger même à l'intérieur du département
donc si vous voulez on a tiré le
meilleur parti d'une situation qui est l
absence de contraintes de mobilité dans
le cadre de la mise en oeuvre du ppmg
qui apparaît singulièrement réduit les
marges de manoeuvre en termes de
rationalisation aux branches dans toute
négociation
j'allais dire de personnel bas c'est un
peu donnant donnant si on revalorise
comme on l'a fait d'ailleurs pour le png
les les les indemnités du personnel
il est assez logique qu'en échange les
agents se voit je dirais pressé de façon
plus insistants d'accepter des mobilités
c'est tout à fait logique donc donc
voilà en réponse à votre question
mes chers collègues nous avons cinq
demandes de parole gse cette mission qui
est fort désagréable d'être maître du
tango qu'il nous reste 10 minutes donc
antoine lefèvre et charles guené je
connais la pertinence de vos
interventions et vos qualités de
concision merci chers collègues
merci madame la présidente monsieur
présent monsieur le conseiller
merci d'avoir de ce partage 2-2 de votre
travail est une vraie réflexion qui m'a
amené d'ailleurs à remonter un peu dans
mes dans mes souvenirs de membres de
cette délégation lorsque je suis arrivé
au sénat et que j'avais accompagné dans
son tour de france
edmond hervé qui avait fait un rapport
justement sur la mise en place notamment
de la réate et demain ce serait
intéressant de reprendre ce rapport par
rapport aux objectifs initiaux de cette
réforme d'ampleur et vous avez ski c'est
un certain de deux remarques de
critiques et surtout des propositions
d'adaptation je crois que c'est
important de même que
certains collègues ont évoqué pour les
sous préfectures il est important dans
nos territoires
on l'a vu au sortir de cette crise
sanitaire ou les a fallu faire preuve de
proximité combien nos sous préfet
d'arrondissement 4 soit d'ailleurs là la
taille des sous-préfectures devait être
ont été à la manoeuvre est souvent
lorsque les équipes sont sont démunis on
avait déjà eu l'occasion de dire que
quand on retire le le chauffeur le
cuisinier est parfois un attaché c'est
les équipes sont sont quand même réduite
et et nos sous préfet doivent faire
preuve de beaucoup d'imagination et
d'être extrêmement présents moi je
voudrais revenir sur la thématique de du
numérique parce que vous avez dit et
combien
l'ambition était forte et moi j'ai été
frappé aussi dans le cas d'un autre
travail d'un rapport que j'ai fait
notamment sur alors ça concerne le
ministère de la justice et le
recouvrement des amendes pénales mais
lorsque vous avez cité l'exemple de des
saisies manuelles ou en fait ces cinq
cent mille fiche d'amande pénale qui
devait être saisie une deuxième fois et
finalement on trouve les similitudes moi
je voudrais poser une question justement
sûr si on veut rationaliser vous le
savez dit combien c'était essentiel
comment on peut justement améliorer
l'expertisé et je crois aussi devoir le
dire la montée en compétence peut-être
même au sein même des administrations
centrales pour que lorsqu'on est la mort
des logiciels et des outils
informatiques de numérisation de
dématérialisation on puisse être le plus
pertinent possible alors je ne suis pas
spécialiste de ces questions comme notre
collègue philippe dallier mais
l'informatique c'est important mais il
faut aussi que
ça suive à tous les maillons de la
chaîne donc comment justement sur ces
aspects là on peut rapidement et
efficacement améliorer les choses merci
charles avec autant de concision que ton
talent le permet il est grand merci
charles
merci madame la présidente d'une
remarqué et une question monsieur le
président monsieur le conseiller m
simplement elle est peut-être en limite
de notre exercice mais je partage avec
vous la vie que que l'état est en
général bien rester présent sur le
territoire mobile au le le mouvement de
l'est de la dgfip plutôt assez vaste
mais je pense que la question qui se
pose est plutôt de savoir s'ils iront et
vie joue toujours le rôle attendu alors
vous indiquer que n'a pas toujours fixé
ses missions prioritaires et qu'il a
fait le nom mode éthique elle souvent je
sais que je partage avec vous qu'il est
que souvent l'obstacle les souvent les
problèmes de mobilité du personnel et
notamment des cadres mais avez vous
faire un travail prospectif sur comment
faire à apporter aux services de l'état
des réponses on va dire contemporaine
qui l'a t on à nouveau parce que
effectivement on parle du numérique mais
le numérique ça n'est qu'un pour moi ça
n'est qu'un moyen
et effectivement le le conseiller maître
jean michel lair l'a évoqué sur le sujet
des maisons services qui répondent un
petit peu à ces nouvelles vocations de
l'administration mais ce que je veux
dire c'est que on voit très bien qu'à ce
niveau les chèques en question enfin
d'échec partiel de deux de ses maisons
et donc de la présence de l'état pour
accompagner les usagers en fait provoque
un transfert de charges sur les
collectivités locales
et c'est là que le sujet celda quel
sujet à mon sens est est ce que vous
avez travaillé sur cet aspect merci
bien monsieur le président si vous
pouvez répondre merci merci merci
beaucoup madame la présidente et merci
aux sénateurs lefebvre et aux sénateurs
guinée pour l'heure leurs questions sur
le premier point sur la conduite du
changement en numérique
alors nous avons fait pour votre
commission des finances rapport sur la
conduite des grands projets numériques
de l'état c'est un rapport moi je
connaissais rien à tout ça il sait des
rapports que je dois dire c'est le plus
intéressant que j'ai eu la chance de
faire est la cour des comptes de mon
point de vue mais parce que il est
pratiqué y donne un certain nombre de
prescriptions de méthode sur comment
bien conduire un projet numérique et
nous avons travaillé avec un souci
j'avais dire sousse le souci de délivrer
des messages et des recommandations
pratiques et opérationnelles je dirais
il faut partir de l'usagé c'est l'usager
qui doit qui est ce qu'on se le service
qu'on entend lui rendent qui doit être
coquin du projet il faut conduire peu de
projets les conduire vite il faut
introduire un projet numérique non pas à
la réglementation et à fonctionnement
inchangé du service mais en faire
l'occasion d'une transformation du
service si le problème des cartes et
gris s'est posée comme ne vous l'a
rappelé jean michel euler c'est qu'on
avait négligé de simplifier une
règlementation tout à fait absurde dans
ses excès de 2
de précision avant avant de numériser et
c'est un rapport où je crois il n'a pas
vieilli sur la il a été rendu il ya un
peu plus d'un an et demi sur les
prescriptions qu'on peut qu'on peut
faire pour conduire à bien n'ont pas un
projet informatique mais un changement
numérique en embrassant le service rendu
au public et le le le fonctionnement
même du principe de fonctionnement du
service concerné alors je mets sur le
sénateur guinée j'ai avec nous n'avons
pas je crois me mener de de travail
prospectif sur l'évolution des
transferts de charges pouvant résulter
je dirais de la difficulté pour l'état à
maintenir certains services de proximité
du coup le report qui peut ça être
opérés sur les collectivités
territoriales alors on là précisément
chiffré dans le cas du ppn g puisque les
services de l'état ont contracté si je
puis dire avec un certaine nombre de
mairie pour procéder au recueil des des
empreintes digitales et aux prises de
photographie pour la délivrance
automatisé ou numériser des documents et
là il ya des chiffres puisque aussi bien
il ya des compensations effective qui
sont qui sont versés par par l'état mais
c'est un problème plus vaste auquel je
trouve en effet nous devrions nous
intéresser davantage généralement le
rapport annuel de finances publiques
locales comporte des éléments sur les
transferts de charges
mais le problème précis que je pourrait
caractériser ainsi
le le fait que se retourne vers les
collectivités locales de proximité tout
particulièrement les communes un certain
nombre de
personnes qui ne trouvent plus
suffisamment de
je dirais service public d'état de
proximité et ce qui à cette occasion
transferts de charges et si oui quelle
est la quelle en est la mesure je ne
peux pas donner réponse à cette question
aujourd'hui on est marqué à la fois par
la la crise de gilet jaune et la crise
sanitaire de lakovic 19 qui ont conduit
c'est tout une bonne chose nombre
d'observateurs et sans doute d'acteurs
de la vie publique à retourner à
retomber sur terre sur le plancher des
vaches
et on peut dire l'explosion de l'école
et de l'économie numérique qui envahit
la vie quotidienne des gens comme le
fonctionnement des institutions
d'ailleurs aucune donnée quelques temps
l'impression que tous deux jeunes et
virtuels que tout se passait sur les
réseaux sociaux que l'on choisissait ses
communautés d'appartenance le légat
femmes suffirait à répondre aux besoins
individuels constituerait la nouvelle
architecture le collectif transcendant
les gars femmes bien sûr les nations ou
autant sur le plan intellectuel que sur
le plan finances et à leur dispute en
finalement la souveraineté abolissant
les corps intermédiaires
après on veut tenir dans beaucoup de
pays des mouvements populaires d'un type
nouveau
souvent peu provenant des réseaux
sociaux comme des espèces de flash mob
les printemps arabes
les parapluies hong kong les habiller en
espagne connaissent plus loin
d'atterrissage où une récupération
politique mais leurs caractéristiques
communes
je pense c'est de vouloir rené occuper
l'espace public il ya eu aussi occuper
wall street
réoccuper l'espace public avec un
symbole concret alors en france ce
furent les liaisons qui au départ ne
demandait ni le rythme ni la suppression
de l'ena mais simplement que l'on opposé
à l'augmentation de la taxe sur le
gasoil et il voulait plus généralement
que tous les handicaps supporté par les
habitants des périphéries soit a soit
levée on re découvre l'espace et le
temps
la gestion du maintien de l'ordre lors
de ces événements a donné lieu à de
nombreuses critiques et certaines leçons
ont été tirés mais il en est une à mon
sens qui restent a affirmé c'est qu'on
ne peut assurer le rétablissement et le
maintien de l'ordre que de près comme
jeudi à portée de boulons et de pagés à
500 km devant le mur d'écrans on croit
maîtriser la situation mais on risque de
faire le matin en face à face ont
négocié jusqu'au bout c'est pourquoi il
faut sur place dans chaque département
une autorité responsable du fait que
force restera à la loi de la république
et jusqu'à présent cela s'appelle un
préfet alors j'appelle le votre
attention sur vigilance avoir sur les
réformes des services territoriaux de la
sécurité j'utilise ce mot moi je n'aime
pas le mot forces de sécurité intérieure
et plein d'illusions on pourra y revenir
si mon avenir peut vous intéresser
attention à la réforme il faut bien que
ce soit une autorité administrative
civile qui met en branle la force
publique qui ne peut pas se mettre en
branle tout seul donc gilet jaune déjà
une grosse perturbation de la vie
sociale et nationale
et puis la pandémie nul n'a pu nier le
caractère chaotique de la gestion de la
crise sanitaire
certes le virus était inconnu mais la
france disposait d'un plan pandémie
interministérielle qui aurait permis une
gestion territoriale différencier sur le
terrain par les préfets en lien avec
l'ensemble des acteurs au premier chef
les verts et les collectivités
territoriales
ce plan n'a pas été déclenché
ce choix incompréhensibles a été jour de
conséquences on s'est contenté plan
sectoriel horse and géré par les airs
alors tardivement
on a relevé combler le couple maires
préfets mais pour bien vite l'oublier
or ce n'est pas vraiment lié aux
qualités centralisé ou pas de notre
organisation administrative dans les
pays fédéraux d'autonomie ils ont dû
prendre dès mars 2020 des têtes pour
permettre
à l'autorité nationale nonobstant la
compétence de droit commun par exemple
en allemagne des länder
il ya une loi coordonnées capacité
d'action à la chancelière est et ce qui
est important en fait l'efficacité a
dépendu de quoi en réalité de la
capacité de coordination entre toutes
les différentes autorités
un rôle que ni le ministre de la santé
au niveau nat lundi les ars au niveau
territorial ne pouvait jouer alors le
constat c'est que ben non nous ne sommes
pas des avatars dans un monde virtuel
nous sommes des individus en chair et en
os qui se déplacent qui ont des besoins
vitaux qui s'affrontent parfois
physiquement qui souffrent et qui
peuvent mourir et toutes ces réalités
nécessite une organisation collective
sur le terrain et ce sont les missions
des services territoriaux de l'état
alors j'écarte j'écarte le futile à ce
stade l'hypothèse de la disparition du
préfet et de sombres remplacement
éventuel
ça a été bloqué quelques fois dans
différentes phases de la
décentralisation pas un élu
ministre-président au gouverneur en
effet nous sommes sous le régime de la
réforme constitutionnelle de 2003
accompagnant l'acte ii de la
décentralisation qui a confirmé
l'organisation de type préfectoral nous
tendent en modifiant le statut
en effet jusqu'à 2003 l'article 72 de la
constitution parler d'un délégué du
gouvernement dans une circonscription
administrative de l'état et que depuis
le 29 mars 2003 le préfet est un
représentant dans les collectivités
territoriales
il y a donc un ancrage du prêt de faire
vis-à-vis des collectivités
territoriales et je considère qu'il a
des devoirs à leur égard que c'est
constitutionnel y mettre huit délégués
du gouvernement même si le côté
politique de cette fonction subsiste
puisqu'il est quand même le représentant
de chacun des membres du gouvernement
auprès de ces collectivités
territoriales ça permet de rappeler
que l'éducation nationale les financer
aujourd'hui la santé même s' il
s'organise en autonomie sur le
territoire et bien non le ministre leur
ministre n'a qu'un seul représentant le
pressent la rédaction de 2003 rajouter
l'expression représentant de l'état ce
qui entérine est en fait une formule qui
était déjà bien présent dans les lois
les décrets et pour moi je traduis cette
double fonction par eux
cet adage que madame la présidente a
déjà dit m'entendre dire le préfet et le
représentant est sur le territoire de
l'état dans sa permanence et des
gouvernements dans leur alternance
alors on parle maintenant elle et sa
maman était annoncé et entériné le nord
cet ex de la suppression du corps
préfectoral
alors pas d'être et ce n'est pas de la
fonction mais du corps et c'est quand
même très important ça n'est pas
contrairement à ce qu'on veut faire
croire à un débat corporatiste en effet
l'institution préfectorale remonte au
consulat mais la création du coeur en
1950 s'inscrivait dans un mouvement de
modernisation de l'administration dans
l'après guerre
à la suite de la création de l'ena en
1945 en littérature nous avaient dressé
des portraits rarement flatteur des
préfets d'avant-guerre mondains ou très
politique recrutant leurs collaborateurs
dans l'oral entourage et cédera donc la
création d'un corps préfectoral est une
rupture c'est une professionnalisation
et la reconnaissance d'un métier
elle s'est accompagnée de la définition
de modalités de recrutement chez les
sous préfets pour l'essentiel mais aussi
d'éléments extérieurs qu'il y soit par
la voie de la promotion interne cadre
national des préfectures du tour
extérieur du détachement
ils sont maintenant ces recrutements
majoritaire chez les sous préfets et
chez les préfets c'est à peu près 55 ans
entre les préfets issus de l'ena et les
autres alors à noter que les précédentes
réformes touchant le corps préfectoral
avait été faite en cohérence
avec des réformes plus large de la
décentralisation et de l'aménagement du
territoire dans 1950 création du corps
1964 modification du statut réforme du
statut qui est accompagné en fait la
mort d'une décentralisation avec la
création de la datar et simultanément
deux directions départementales les
daces d'année un des meilleurs et c'est
lé décret du 10 mai 81 2 instituant les
commissaires de la république et
président de voir les principes de
déconcentration faisait immédiatement
suite à la loi du 2 mars 1982 en lois de
décentralisation la nouvelle
modification du décret statutaire des
traits fins en demi teinte se situer
dans la droite ligne de l'acte 2 de la
décentralisation ni 2003 mais
aujourd'hui il ne s'agit plus de
réformer le statut des corps préfectoral
mais de le supprimer sans que l'on
puisse discerner de lien évident avec
une grande étape de la décentralisation
car je suis pas sûr qu'on puisse
qualifier ainsi le projet cap nord cet
impact de la fonctionnalisation on peut
dire au fond est-ce bien s'hydrater
elle va permettre le recrutement de près
fait concrètement extérieur ou services
publics dans des proportions non
contingenté je n'y suis allé en poste il
jolie pratiqué en tant que gestionnaire
du corps mais il faut des proportions
les préfets ont toujours été nommé
revendre évoqué à la discrétion du
gouvernement les frais du président de
la république passage en conseil des
ministres et comme je dis nous avons
entre le préfère mandats de sept jours
renouvelables on le sait mais le le
pourcentage de préfet complètement
extérieur à l'administration était
limitée à l'origine au cinquième de
l'effectif global pourcentage qui a été
porté au tiers en 2009 donc au moment où
gp secrétaire général du nist en tant
que gestionnaire du port j'ai pratiqué
ces recrutements veut diversifiée qui
ad'autres maîtrise et apporte une
expérience différente et enrichit le
métier
mais si l'on ne veut pas perdre en
compétences c'est quand même très
compliqué à gérer
déjà une nomination de préfets c'est une
alchimie subtile on doit trouver la
correspondance entre un profil c'est pas
seulement des compétences c'est aussi un
tempérament avec une collectivité
départementale son terrain ses
caractéristiques c est lui aussi et
enfin des circonstances et des enjeux
qui sont variables dans le temps est
assez commun à toutes les nominations et
préfectorales s'ajoute pour les apports
extérieurs à la mise en place d'une
formation d'un manteau en plus ou moins
formalisés et l'accueil par une équipe
de collaborateurs solides qui vont
initier leurs patrons aux spécificités
du métier la gestion des corps elle est
rayé pour moi connaissant structurelles
et conjoncturelles du territoire c'est
pourquoi son transfert éventuel à la
diète directions interministérielles
veulent entendre un supérieur serait
pour moi une perte de lien avec le
territoire
ce serait pas une bonne chose il faut
éviter et rester garder une gestion du
corps dans l année matin au ministère de
matéri pour résumer la
fonctionnalisation remporté plusieurs
risques un excès de politisation une
perte de compétences et une mauvaise
adéquation aux collectivités
territoriales alors à ce stade
voudrait on l'interrogé avec vous sur la
notion de la cadres dirigeants et sur la
notion de corps intermédiaires car dans
cette réforme de la haute fonction
publique on voit disparaître en réalité
la notion de cadre dirigeant de métiers
actuellement on considère qu environ les
six ans aux fonctionnaires nommés en
france l élite constituent les cadres
dirigeants d'états et aujourd'hui on
nous parle plus que une vaste catégorie
d'encadrement supérieur de l'état à
d'abord entendu les 12000 maintenance et
les crédits
mais alors est-ce que les hauts
fonctionnaires de métiers sont voués à
la simple mise en oeuvre comme le répète
la ministre la transformation public ou
bien sont ils toujours des
fonctionnaires de conception et de
direction alors cet écrasement de la
hiérarchie il constata dans l'est dans
les grandes entreprises les gars femme
que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
il ya quelques génies créateurs et puis
ensuite des gens sûrement très diplômés
mais qui sont là pour la maison cet
écrasement de la hiérarchie ne
procède-t-elle pas du même mouvement de
contournement des corps intermédiaires
que les collectivités locales ont pu
constater à leur détriment dans la
gestion d'apprendre or les politiques
publiques sont très souvent partagée
entre l'état et les collectivités
locales
et elles ne peuvent être conçus sans
associer ce qui services déconcentrés et
collectivités territoriales seront
chargés de leur mise en oeuvre
au risque de passer à côté des
difficultés qui génère en des couacs des
rétro pédalage et c'est à alain 10 c'est
la faiblesse des études d'impact des
textes législatifs ou des évaluations a
priori des politiques publiques
une circulaire du premier ministre du 19
avril 2021 définit la feuille de route
des préfets avec une dizaine
d'indicateurs à choisir parmi 68
politiques prioritaires cette méthode
strictement descendante et au moins
regrettable nous nous avions depuis les
années 2000 sa figure toujours dans les
textes l'idée de l'élaboration d'un
projet d'action stratégique de l'état en
région et dans les départements qui
monte lui terrain qui devrait bien sûr
être validé par les ministres eux mêmes
mais qui permettait au préfet d'élaborer
lui même ça fait de route en lien avec
l'ensemble des acteurs locaux et on voit
aussi dans les exercices de
contractualisation entre l'état et les
collectivités territoriales une
insuffisance voire un escamotage de la
phase d' analyse commune etc santé des
besoins de la collectivité et des
populations pour ce résumé parfois à
faire rentrer les projets locaux dans
des cases prédéfinies
alors j'ai entendu sur la fin de la
séquence précédente avec les questions
sur niveau régional au niveau
département alors avec les vagues
successives de décentralisation de
nombreuses missions opérationnelles de
l'état qui étaient pour l'essentiel
exercé au niveau départemental ont été
transférés
aux collectivités territoriales
notamment au département à les routes de
la dde le social de la dass ou alors
commune avec l'urbanisme et à un énorme
paquet dans la décentralisation alors on
pourrait disserter ce n'est sans doute
pas lieu sur la manière dont ces
transferts ont été réalisés et répondant
plus à une logique administratif cas des
blocs de compétences et après figure
vague de transferts il fallait
recomposer dans un périmètre réduit
ayant été rapporteur général de l'ars et
à la réforme de l'aide de l'organisation
administrative de l'étang en 2007
j'avais essayé de fonder cette
réorganisation sur quelques principes
directeurs j'ai proposé que les services
régionaux regroupées dans le hall e
préfigurant les directions correspondant
au bloc ministériel qui puisse attirer
des expertises spécialisées dont l'état
a toujours besoin sur le territoire soit
consolidée on pouvait observer déjà les
peuples et depuis longtemps que cette
expertise n'existait plus sauf exception
au niveau départemental il fallait
éviter les doublons aussi avec les
collectivités territoriales
en revanche il fallait répondre aux
besoins de proximité de la population et
notamment au regard de l'extension de la
numérisation de l'administration et des
téléprocédures il fallait donc je vais
organiser les services départementaux
greta non plus selon des découpages
ministériel dé selon un élu local
selon les besoins des citoyens des
usagers et contribuer à organiser
certaines administrations s'étant
exonérés de cet exercice éducation
finances et même santé et bien les
missions interministérielles pouvait
être recomposée autour de la mission
générale de l'état sur le territoire
mission de protection protection des
personnes et protection des territoires
alors sur les endroits ça donné lieu à
deux ou trois directions
interministérielles
lokad simultanément j'avais proposé que
l'on valide ça existait déjà mais que
l'on veut rendre plus claire la
subordination des préfets de
départements aux préfets de région
s'agissant de l'adaptation et de la mise
en oeuvre des politiques publiques
en revanche je
j'avais proposé ça est évidemment
adopter une responsabilité totale du
préfet de département pour la sécurité
la gestion de crise et la gestion de
l'immigration
c'est ce qui a été inscrit dans le
décret de 2009 met alors à la création
des grandes régions a bousculé cet
équilibre et appelle sans doute une
reconfiguration du réseau y compris que
jusqu'au réseau va des sous préfets
alors une circulaire du premier ministre
du 12 juin 2009 c'était le précédent
gouvernement relative à l'organisation
territoriale de l'état affichent de
bonnes intentions
ceci dit simultanément la gentrification
et l'autonomie de certaines
administrations n'ont pas été remises en
voilà alors pour conclure ce propos
introductif jeu je pense que
l'organisation territoriale de l'état à
un lien fort avec celle des
collectivités territoriales mais n'est
cependant pas séparable de l'évolution
de l'état central et de ses opérateurs
une partie de la réponse réside dans l'
architecture de la lolf et la portée de
ces programmes
il ya eu des efforts entrepris pour
éviter la constitution de trop nombreux
silo qui se voudrait autarcique et peu
enclin à la déconcentration
mais ses efforts sont encore trop léger
anouk déterminant des missions de l'état
c'est la judiciarisation de l'action
publique qui que fait encourir un risque
pénal personnel à de nombreux agents du
service public et la même chose je crois
pour les élus locaux et son origine soit
nationale ou européenne
ce processus engendre une inflation des
fonctions d'inspection et de contrôle
on le dénonce souvent dans les séries
les battre aux inspections et contrôles
pas sept conseils et de facilitation
mais il faut aller à l'origine de cette
dérive
par ailleurs évidemment il ya une
réflexion à mener sur le périmètre même
de l'action publique mais c'est une
autre affaire voilà je remercie
si madame la préfète j'ai tout de suite
passé la parole à nos collègues donc je
propose d'inverser si vous êtes d'accord
donc en proposant d'abord à eric et
rouge puis agnès canayer jour merci
chers collègues damas prochain merci
beaucoup je vous appelle je vous appelle
ainsi parce que en fait vous êtes
beaucoup intervenu à ce titre d'une
certaine façon quand votre dans les
propos que vous avez que vous avez tenus
s'agissant de s'agissant de la rue moi
qui ai beaucoup travaillé sur la
socialisation dans le corps dans le
corps préfectoral
je pense que vous avez insisté sur les
effets pervers que pourrait avoir un
déséquilibre trop des équipes pardon
progressif dans le corps et je pense que
c'est sans doute là la menace qui plane
avec avec cette raison être préfets ou
sous préfets c'est aussi apprendre une
certaine socialisation est entre
guillemets je ne sais pas comment le
dire autrement le métier de l'état
l'équilibré subtil et je crois que la
fin du corps n'a rien à voir avec
quelque chose de une protection de de
quelque chose qui ferait la défense d'un
groupe i mais plutôt de la nécessité du
maintien d'une certaine culture
préfectoral qui risque d'être mise en
cause dans le temps et de déséquilibrer
la gouvernance de de nos territoires et
je pense comme vous qu'il ya un vrai
problème avec la fin du corps parce que
celui ci et vous avez insisté là dessus
est grandement ouvert déjà sur
l'extérieur mais il ne veut pas être
couverts sur l'extérieur parce que sinon
on ira vers une politisation à l'extrême
qui ne répondra pas aux besoins aux
besoins des territoires
donc peut-être avait plus
loin sur sur les risques que laissant
courir 7,7
cette réforme il ya la question aussi du
coup de l'attractivité de ce corps en
tant que tel dans la réforme telle
qu'elle serait telle qu'elle serait
prévu pour faire court deuxième question
il ya beaucoup de travaux qui portent
sur l'externalisation de l'état de
multiples de multiples façons et on a vu
récemment le recours qui est fait à une
manoeuvre contractuelles notamment dans
l'est dans les sous préfectures
je vais être un peu rapide mais est ce
qu'on peut faire fonctionner l'état avec
thé avec des béquilles sur les
territoires est-ce que ça encore un sens
de maintenir ces institutions alors que
dans les faits elle représente parfois
des des coquilles des coquilles vides et
je m'en tiendrai là
merci beaucoup agnès oui merci à la
présidente mana préfère effectivement la
latitude est grandissante aux habitants
de l'occasion de révéler sur cette
disparition du corps des préfets des
annonces sur la fonction elle même et
sur les conséquences en terme de deux
places du préfet au sein de
l'administration territoriale et
notamment sur ta qu'aujourd'hui il ya
une remontée forte du fait que les
préfets sont avant tout des personnes
qui font descendre l'information des
ministères et qui n'ont plus un rôle
d'accompagnement et de remonter de
proximité souvent les élus locaux à
commencer par les maires se plaignent de
la possibilité d'avoir auprès de la
préfecture ou sous-préfecture des
informations en amont sur les politiques
publiques sur les dossiers sur les
actions qu'il mène et d'avoir toujours
une relation avant tout de contrôle et
de sanction et donc ne pensez vous pas
que cette réforme du corps préfectoral
va amplifier encore aujourd'hui en
rendons encore plus le représentant de
l'état dans le territoire comme une
autorité descendante
ça c'est une première chose je ne
reviendrai pas sur la contractualisation
mon collègue kerrouche la relever on
voit ce qui se passe dans la justice
avec la mise en place de sucres rapides
et de contracte de contractuels qui
viennent de compenser mais qui n'ont pas
objectivement la connaissance et la
formation pourrait être aussi optimum
que les fonctionnaires des dessertes
magana question concerne aussi la
représentation dans le territoire on
voit que l'efficacité aujourd'hui de
l'administration territoriale de l'état
repose dans la proximité le lien humain
l'année ses contacts
aujourd'hui les maisons français en lice
vous paraît ce thème ma question sera
celle de répondre à ces dangers de
proximité merci beaucoup mais là mme la
préfète je vous propose de répondre
et si des collègues souhaitent
intervenir merci de nous le signaler
madame la préfète oui monsieur le
sénateur un quart en chef je suis tout à
fait en accord avec ce que dénonce est
effectivement euro souligne aisément le
risque de la politisation on souligne -
effectivement l'évolution ou même du
métier qui est un hacker de vocation il
a beaucoup de contraintes et donc il ya
un problème d'attractivité à nous tendre
vers des nominations extérieur qui
prendrait des proportions au delà du
tiers autorisés jusqu'à présent pour
aller beaucoup plus loin
ça voudrait dire que les sous-préfets
préfet table
eux ne n'aurait pas de perspectives de
carrière et qu'il serait même invités à
former leur patron au métier il faut
beaucoup d'abnégation et disons que même
si la vocation préfectoral le nécessite
aussi de l'abnégation
ça peut pas durer toute la vie donc il
ya un réel problème d'attractivité et je
pense que oui il ne faut pas aller dans
ce sens mais je l'avais que examiner
cette idée de fonctionnalisation à
l'époque c'était une demande du
politique d'étudier de regarder s'il
faut pas me changer tous ces corps
simplifiée mais tolère ça s'était
traduit par le passage au tiers plutôt
que 20 % et on avait j'avais pas mal de
difficultés quand même à trouver eux des
candidats qu'ils veuillent bien venant
de l'extérieur avec un autre métier avec
un autre cursus devenir préfet et
accepter toutes les contraintes des
métiers préfectoral alors sur la
question de l'externalisation et de
recours contractuel pour moi il ya
plusieurs niveaux il y à des expertises
pointues que l'état ne peut pas
développer en son sein et que parce que
c'est des choses extrêmement évolutive
il faut être dans des équipes qui se
consacre peu à temps complet depuis des
années à tel sujet il faut aller les
chercher comme dans le monde académique
dans le monde de l'entreprise et l'état
n'a qu'à gagner le service public en
général d'akadêmia des recours à des
expertises sont autre chose et la
délégation du service public
elle ne sert existe mais ça doit être
encadré ça doit être contrôlé et on doit
garder la caf et la capacité de maîtrise
d'ouvragé pour énoncer le besoin que
l'on veut voir ouvrir par
l'externalisation quentin laon gauche
de contractuels pour boucher des trous
pour faire face à une insuffisante
attractivité de certaines localisations
je pense que effectivement ça c'est un
élément qui doit rentrer en ligne de
compte lorsque l'on réfléchit à l'art
configuration du réseau territorial
qu'est ce qui fait qu'on n'arrive pas à
recruter les gens pour aller dans tel ou
tel sous préfecture bon il faut rajouter
aussi dans le recours à
l'externalisation aux contractuels que
certains sujets on était occulté
volontairement ou pas ce qui ce qui a
saturé les services préfectoraux à un
moment donné et qui a obligé d'avoir des
recours aux contractuels et ça a été la
poussée de la gestion des migrations
alors ça va pas ça pas pu être entérinée
au niveau politique on n'a pas
suffisamment dit que c'était un problème
à gérer et qu'il fallait du mans pour le
gérer mais quand on voit la queue aux
portes des préfectures et les sous
préfectures
ce sont des étrangers qui sont là en
demande d'étude de leur dossier
effectivement et il a fallu avoir
recours à 1,10 à des contractuels pour
essayer de répondre à cette aune là
aussi il ya une question l'organisation
du réseau territorial de l'état avait
préfecture et des sous préfectures mais
aussi de tous les réseaux des
administrations
elle doit procéder quand même d'une
analyse objective de ce que le pouvoir
politique et nationale veut faire si on
ferme les yeux sur les questions de
l'immigration et qu'on dit que ça
n'existe pas évidemment on ne viendra
pas créer des emplois ou maintenir les
emplois ou retraités dossier alors donc
renvoie quand même vers
vers la prise en compte par le politique
de la réalité sociale et territoriale
mais la sénatrice
oui ils vous l'avez bien le
effectivement le préfet de plus en plus
comme c'est beau le descendant et jeudi
at on besoin d'avoir un cadre dirigeant
pour faire ce métier avec les réseaux
sociaux avec l'internet tout le monde
peut quasiment voir en dire est ce que
décide le moment ce que débat le
parlement
et finalement tout le monde peut se
retrouver à peu près au même niveau
d'information
mais c'est après quatre dernières et
subtilité et quand vous avez que des
programmes européens quand vous avez des
contrats beauté dohrn ans après les
conséquences de la crise sanitaire
vous vous trouvez avec des tableaux
énorme calendrier des appels à projets
avec toute une série de conditions à
remplir
et comme je le disais plus tôt que
d'élaborer un projet territorial comme
on l'a fait en tout cas du temps que
j'étais préfet j'ai fait mon projet
d'action stratégie pour les temps en
lorraine j'ai fait mon projet d'action
stratégique pour les temps en bretagne
en lien évident avec tous les acteurs
locaux à partir de 100 remonte pour
faire valider par les ministres et on
peut aller vers la contractualisation et
se doter dans la feuille de route des
priorités de l'état
je relis samoa à une tendance
managériales que l'on retrouve partout
vous le trouvez dans l'entreprise les
débats sur l'écrasement
le malaise des cadres et l'écrasement vd
hiérarchie intermédiaire il existe aussi
au sein de l'état alors jusqu'à présent
on le voyait plutôt chez les les
les cadres intermédiaires mais pour le
chef du bureau
qui avec la généralisation des
téléprocédures n'avait plus le même
contrôle sur les opérateurs de base et
maintenant est-ce que ça n'est pas en
train de frapper à leur faune et les
directeurs les cadres dirigeants des
administrations centrales et ceux qui
étaient encore pour l'instant des
dirigeants sur le territoire alors
l'occurrence les préfets si on a
simplement à commenter est ce que tout
le monde peut voir de la bonne parole
ministériel voire présidentielle bon
c'est ici
est ce que c'est vraiment un métier et à
ce moment là évidemment on peut imaginer
avoir des amateurs de proches du pouvoir
politique qui seront sans doute des
meilleurs commentateurs de la parole de
l'autorité supérieure que un haut
fonctionnaire blanchi sous le harnais et
ayant intégré une culture de l'état dans
sa permanence
alors on s'est tu
cette tendance c'est pas une question je
crois qu'il faut pas ramener ça à
centralisation décentralisation c'est
une fin c'est une question de ycompris
de fonctionnement interne de l'état et
c'est même pas une question de
déconcentration ou pas même si
évidemment plus de déconcentration et
plus de responsabilité donne plus de
marge de manoeuvre et je pense que ça va
au-delà c est une méthode je dirais
presque de gouvernance avec un
affadissement 1,10 politique un
affadissement de la responsabilité qui
ne devait de la responsabilité politique
ou de la responsabilité administrative
qui est supplantée par la responsabilité
pénale et est ce qu on a le droit de me
poser la question du pourquoi
il ya eu différentes raisons à là la
gestion est très curieuse chaotique de
la crise sanitaire
l'une des deux hypothèses que jenny c
est bien finalement avec les
identifications par un petit peu tout le
monde des risques pénaux dans la gestion
de ce type de crise on a fait remonter
ça jusqu'au sol le responsable qui ne
puisse voir engager sa responsabilité au
moins quand on est président la
république et donc ce dispositif faisant
de façon vraiment assez absurde tout
remonter avec un conseil de défense sans
transparence alors même que l'efficacité
dans la gestion d'une crise suppose que
chacun des acteurs soient conscients son
rôle
conscient de ses marges de manoeuvre est
conscient de ses relations avec les
autres responsables et au lieu de ça
chacun était à l'écouté à 18h tél
nous on avait l'impression que après un
peu du teasing entre différentes
hypothèses
c'était presque le hasard qui faisait
que telle ou telle décision tombait donc
effectivement cette notion que de
d'autorité descendante
elle est liée aussi à cette conception
un affadissement de la responsabilité
politique et administrative au prochain
j'ai une responsabilité pénale
conjugué à une mode jeune âge et rial
d'écrasement des décors et des
hiérarchies intermédiaire alors
maintenant la représentation sur sur le
territoire voilà puisqu'il ya aussi bien
entendu je ne le dis pas à un aspect
très important de mise en oeuvre des
produits et dans cette mise en oeuvre
des politiques effectivement on a des
outils avec maintenant les
téléprocédures avec un accès de plus en
plus large à des données
et il faut des médiateurs alors on ne
peut pas il ya vu les différentes
époques à la maison de l'état la maison
du service public la maison des services
au public français service tous à
procéder un petit peu des mêmes idées là
je n'ai pas participé aux évaluations
qui ont pu être faites
les impressions je peux avoir localement
c'est que c'est extrêmement variable
il ya des endroits où s'est fortement
apprécié et d'autre
c'est même peut identifier
[Musique]